my name is bassiuni arima from arlington
texas
mr buffett and mr monger with the
possibility to use these two great mind
of
for a long term in life by
either taking uh apprenticeship
in brookshire or
obvious school
i didn't follow that one lately you
answered the question what what what the
possibility using these two great minds
of yours to uh to educate a new
generation
uh
as a long-term investment in the in this
country
to either through apprenticeship in
brookshire for young people
or
open a business school well let me try
that one because i have a demonstrated
record of non-performance
i have had great difficulty
enabling my children to know what i know
and
one
maybe you have failed less
my children in many ways are a lot
smarter than i am so i had a different
experience charlie
so i i think you can um you know i i've
mainly learned by reading myself so i i
i don't i don't think i have any
original ideas that uh
i certainly uh
but i've certainly got a lot i mean i've
talked about reading
graham i read phil fisher and uh
i've i've gotten a lot of ideas
myself from reading and uh
in my own case i mean to talk about your
parents having influences and you know
my parents had enormous influence so i i
think you can i think you can learn a
lot from other people in fact i think if
you learn reasonably well from other
people you don't have to get any new
ideas or do much on your own you can
just apply the best of what you see
generally speaking i think we always get
a group of
of wise people
after sifting millions
but
i don't think anybody's invented a way
to
teach so that
everybody is wise
it's extraordinary how
resistant some people are learning
anything
well and really what it's astounding is
this is how resistant they are when it's
they're so in their self-interest to
learn i mean
i was always astounded by
by how
much attention was was paid to graham i
mean he was he was regarded 40 years ago
as the dean of security analysts but how
little attention was paid in terms of
the principles he taught and
it wasn't because people were refuting
them and it wasn't because people didn't
have a self-interest in the in learning
sound investment principles that it was
just this
incredible resistance to thinking or
change i mean i quoted
bertrand russell one time as saying who
said that
most men would rather die than think
many have you know and
in the financial sense that's
that's very true it
it
it's not complicated i mean human
relations you know usually aren't that
complicated but
and certainly it's people's
self-interest to develop
uh habits that work
well in human relations but
uh an amazing number of people seem to
mess it up one way or another yeah
how much has berkshire hathaway been
copied
either in investing america or corporate
america
i'm not saying we deserve to be
necessarily but
but
people don't want to do it
differently
than they're presently doing it
you might argue that
mrs b having started what you may have
seen out there this weekend
with 500 in 1937
you know with without a day in school in
our life
and building that into a great
enterprise you might say well that is
something to study i mean it
you know is it because she
couldn't speak english when we got you
know she got over here maybe
people i mean what what are the you know
what is there to learn
from seeing somebody create an
incredible success like that in a
competitive business she didn't invent
something that
that
the world had never seen before she
didn't have a lock on some piece of real
estate that protected her from
competition
you know all of these
and yet she accomplished something that
virtually
no one has accomplished
now why aren't business schools studying
her you know why are they talking about
eva you know economic value added as we
talked about earlier or anything i mean
here is a success something has made her
a success
you know is it something is it a two
hundred and two she's very smart but is
it a 220 iq no it isn't it's a very
smart woman but it's not it's not
something that's incapable of being
replicated in
the habits and the way of thinking
but who is studying here i mean they
present her as a curiosity
but if you go to any of the top 20
business schools
you know there's not one page
that's being given to anybody to study
what is an incredible success and i it i
i just i find that very interesting that
uh
and to some extent you know i've seen it
in the investment world
there's this
for one thing the high you know it it's
probably a little discouraging to a
professor of management
in some major business school that
has gone on to get his doctorate and
everything to think he has to
come out and hang around the furniture
mart
study a woman in a golf cart i mean
but
you're good they'd be better off if they
did
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you